The Lion Queen of the Animal Kingdom has added a legislature to the government.
To let his citizens enjoy more democracy
Every citizen has one vote and is divided into constituencies. Each constituency will elect a representative
Come to the newly formed jungle council
In order to understand how this system works, let’s look at a small colony with only two parties.
Bison Party and Antler Rabbit Party
This colony is divided into four constituencies. Candidate for the Rabbit Party in the first election
Won two constituencies, and the candidates of the Niu Party won the remaining constituencies
After a few election cycles, everything worked fine. Until the animal kingdom census enumerator came over and investigated
And found that the population here has migrated and grown
So in order to better reflect the population growth, a new seat has been added to the jungle council.
This leads to the need to re-divide the boundaries of the constituency here.
This is a trouble. Redistributing the constituency is a major political problem
To help them, the representative of the Jungle Council hired a weasel consultant.
To figure out how to divide the new boundary
If the weasel turns the constituency into a rectangle, everything is fine, because of this, the jungle council
The true situation of voters who can be as close as possible
However, the weasel did not do this. Instead he told the Buffalo Party that he was willing to pay
He can turn their weak majority into an overwhelming victory in the election.
If the Bison Party has an absolute majority in the jungle council, they will never hear those annoying antler rabbit parties.
The obstruction of the proceedings, so the cattle party was happy to pay the money
So how should the weasel fulfill his promise? The method is simple and frustrating: just put the voters of the rabbit party
Concentrate on one constituency as much as possible, and spread the other voters to make the ox party
Win a seat, don't let any voter change the party
What the Weasel and Buffalo Party do is called "Jerry's" (selection division)
That is, consciously divide the constituency to make a profit for yourself.
After several election cycles, the antler rabbit party that could not be selected and was not happy found the weasel
And asked if he could manipulate the constituency to help the rabbit party instead of the ox party.
Of course he can. By the same means, the weasel puts the voters of the cattle party
They are concentrated in several constituencies and the rest are diluted to many places where the rabbit party supporters
After the election, the rabbit party, although representing only a minority of the voters
Now it has become the majority party of the jungle council.
This is the terrible power of "Jerry": the same voter
The weasel can let any party win the election.
I am so powerful! Unsurprisingly, the business of the weasels is getting bigger and bigger, and in the end all areas of the animal kingdom
Unsurprisingly, the business of the weasels is getting bigger and bigger, and in the end all areas of the animal kingdom
All paying money to ask him to engage in "Jerry's" in their constituency.
As the number of customers increases, the weasel now uses a well-designed mathematical statistical model of voter voting behavior.
Test hundreds of constituency combinations on a computer to get the results he wants
When the Queen of the Lions discovered the activity of the weasel, he drove him out of the kingdom. But demographer
Remind her that due to population changes, the constituency still has to be re-divided
So how do you decide this?
The Queen of the Lions presented an obvious plan: all new constituencies must be divided
Recognized by a bipartisan committee
This seems like a good idea. After all, if there are divisions recognized by both parties.
Finally, it must be fair to everyone.
However, after several electoral cycles using this approach, the Lion Queen found her in the Jungle Parliament
I can always see some old faces. These representatives almost never
Lose election
The interests of the original representatives are not the same as the interests of the citizens.
The elections that citizens want are candidates who must find ways to earn their own votes.
In such a close-knit election, every party has the same chance to win.
However, the delegates do not want the elections that are evenly matched, they want to win the election
That is, where the majority of their supporters are elected
Since the delegates can decide the division by themselves, they will try their best
Some insurance for the zoning
Then the inter-party committee is not enough. Want to really solve "Jerry"
There are three ways
One is to establish a politically independent committee to divide the constituencies, and the committee members are all designated experts.
Or judge
The independent committee is better than the inter-party committee, but it is not very ideal.
Because they usually put similar areas together, the result of the election is not competitive.
And there are also these independent committees.
Not as likely as they seem to be independent on the surface
The second choice is to divide the selection by mathematical methods. In mathematics, there are many ways
Can divide a region into a constituency of equal population
One of the simplest examples is called "the shortest dividing line method". First find the voters.
Divide into the shortest line of two equal parts, then repeat the process until all the constituencies are drawn
This method is far better than the "independent" committee, but it is still possible
It is not good to divide the constituency due to accidental luck.
But by publishing the algorithm, all citizens can check and be convinced in the system.
No intentional prejudice
The last method is very surprising: hire the weasel and hug "Jerry"
But this time, spending money to let him put the (selection of the district) in general, the election winners are as close as possible to the wishes of the voters.
Although this method sounds annoying, it is the best way to avoid disproportionate representations.
That is, the biggest disadvantage of "Jerry"
However, thinking of these three solutions makes the Queen of Lions very angry.
The first two are improved, but there is still the possibility of a lack of competition or a disproportionate election result.
And the third method doesn't sound right: relying on "Jerry" to solve the problem of "Jerry"
It feels so...very weird
She now thought of the lessons she learned during the previous elections, and she realized these "Jerry" phenomena.
In fact, it is only the appearance of a more fundamental problem.
That is, each citizen has only one vote and only one candidate’s voting system is selected.
There are many ways to solve "Jerry's" and restore the competitive nature of the election.
To make her citizens happy, but want to do that, the Queen of Lions must
Make some huge, fundamental changes to her democratic system
To be continued...